ou ne plus me joindre à lui dans ce
domaine
parce que comme il y en a qui sont fans
de l'application Tik Tok lui un autre
toc c'est plutôt le bitcock
et à chaque je me suis rendu compte qu'à
chaque fois que je présentais une meuf
il la Kennet et après il l'a bloqué sur
son téléphone mais du coup je me suis
fâché avec des copies à moi qui m'ont
dit mais c'est qui cette ignoble
personnage que tu nous as présenté etc
on entend ce que tu dis là
[Applaudissements]
tu sais qu'est-ce que tu sais qu'on
passe à la télé
il y a 2 millions de personnes qui nous
regardent après
je pense qu'il a surtout envie d'être
ami avec moi je pense que les autres
sont ils sont en famille c'est une belle
personne que j'aime beaucoup c'est pour
ça que j'ai envie de t'adresser un grand
nikoumouk
[Applaudissements]